The case,
and this is practically speaking,
is that it is not at all unreasonable to
think of God the father as the spirit
that arises from the crowd that exists
into the future.
Right,
and that's we talked about that in
relationship to the idea of sacrifice at
least a little bit more,
or we're going to make sacrifices in the
present so that the future is happy with
you.
The question is,
what is that future that would be happy
with you?
And the answer to that is it's the
spirit of humanity.
That's who you're negotiating with
because you make the assumption that if
you forgo impulsive pleasure and get
your medical degree,
that when you're done in 10 years and
you're a physician,
humanity as such will honor your
sacrifice and commitment and open the
doors to you.
Right?
So you're treating the future as if it's
a single being and you're also treating
it as if it's some something like a
compassionate judge.
You're acting that out and maybe we had
to imagine God in that form before we
could understand.
Once we started to understand that there
was a future,
perhaps we had to imagine God in that
form in order to concretize something
that we could bargain with so that we
could figure out how to use sacrifice to
figure out how to guide ourselves into
the future because as sacrifices,
a contract with the future,
but it's not a contract with any
particular person,
it's.
It's a contract with the spirit of
humanity as such.
It's something like that,
and so when you think about it that way,
that should make you faint with
amazement because that is such a bloody
amazing idea to come up with that idea
that you can bargain with the future.
That is some idea,
man.
That's,
that's like the major idea of human,
of humankind.
We suffer.
What do we do about it?
We figured out how to bargain with the
future and we minimize suffering in that
manner.
It's like no other animal does that
either.
You know,
like the lions,
they just eat everything.
I think a wolf can eat 40 pounds of meat
in a single city.
Right?
It's like there's some meat,
eat it.
It's not like save some mammoth for
tomorrow.
That's,
that's,
that's not a wolf thing,
man.
That's a human thing and that might mean
you have to be hungry today or maybe
you're a farmer,
you know,
several thousand years ago,
6,000
years ago or so with agriculture first
got going and you're starving to death
waiting for the spring planting and you
think we built it bloody well,
better not eat those seeds.
Right?
And that's really something to be able
to control yourself,
to make the future real,
to put off what you could use today and
not just in some impulsive manner,
man,
maybe your kids are starving to death.
You think we are not touching the seeds
that we need for the future and for
human beings to have discovered that and
then to also have figured out that we
could bargain with the future.
It's like,
man,
that's something and I think that that.
I think that the stories that are laid
out in this book actually describe,
at least in part the process by which
that occurred.